دكتور احمد يعطيك العافيه عظم الله اجركم
ربنا يرحم تحكيلي ايش اللي صار مع
[موسيقى]
اهلك استهدف البيت
مباشر نستش فيهم بعد
ما اسعاف بعض ال جرحه في مكان اخر في بيت
ثاني ذق البيت مره اخرى طلعت عندي حصيله
الشهداء حتى هي اللحظه بالبيتين من الناس
ومنا من ع 28 شهيد وم ضمهم
الخو
ولاده العين
الثانيه حوالي 20 شهيد وج شهداءهم قرابه
50 شهيد عند الناس من ذلك انه ل حت هي
الواحده ايام عشان كده بطلع اي
حجه الميدان كنت اتوقع هي محظ تصير كل بقت
في غزه واخر
اتوقع بس مش بي
الجرا الحمد لله على ما خرجت ادك خرجتهم
لا مش قادر الاولاد الجيش احتلا موجودين
متواجدين حباب البيت حتى هيظ وكلهم متجين
الاق ما فيش اي وسيله اجل ما ادخل لا
تنسيق ولا في صليب احمر ولا في ان انا بجي
الاحمر الفلسطيني وابن اللج الدوي الاحمر
وشغال على مدار الساعه من 70 يوم مش قال
طول البيت والناس بتكات لنا والناس بتقول
لك احنا بنقدر احنا زينا زي الناس قربت
ادخل اول يوم قام بطلاق النار مباشر علي
فسحبت فان شاء الله نقدر نسحب يصير عد
يصير اي شيء لانه بفي بفي عن جد طب انت
يعني قادر تكمل يعني قادر تكمل في شغلك
كمل هو ما نزلتش عند
السياره عندي كمان 23 اصابه الان نحتويهم
ق من عيلتي عتي اخواتي ولاد اخوتي ولاد
كذا انا براعيهم اصابات وجرحه عندي اصابات
خطيره و بتعامل معهم بايدي وبغير لهم كلهم
الحمد لله مستمر بغيرهم وستمر رغم
عل
السلام